so the way we've been working over the
last few years has been evolving
constantly in the very beginning it was
brandon and freddie nico and myself and
even jimmy all living and working in one
tiny little apartment and from there as
our youtube channels grew we decided
wait a second
we shouldn't be working out of our own
apartment all the time and so this year
we decided let's do this let's get
ourselves an our own studio for corridor
digital and
so we picked the best one
we're very lucky to have a landlord that
is an artist himself and happened to get
this building back in the 70s when
warehouses were not too expensive in los
angeles he makes a point of keeping the
rent affordable for people like us who
are trying to
run creative artistic businesses so
that's awesome so steve if you're
watching this thanks a bunch welcome to
the space we have space right here
without anything in it which is kind of
interesting because we didn't have any
of that in our other place by the time
we were moving out we have a desk right
here where john from mars rising films
helps us out with our behind the scenes
we have a desk right here which is where
sam does his thing
we have a desk right here for
miscellaneous helper number two who uh
has not shown up yet
but will happen someday
here's my desk this is jay says it's a
ping pong table and we got an arcade
machine the back corner that i got for
200 bucks from our neighbors next door
and it still works
yeah crisis zone the best one
we have water
fire extinguisher in case there's fires
we have a pipe um with a valve in case
you need water if you when you get
thirsty you turn it and sprays out of
there take this like right here you roll
it up and you fill it up
we have our
youtube award for getting a million
subscribers
a giant play button
we have our webby
before everything was packed into one
space it was really disorganized it was
really hard for us to go out and
basically do a shoot because we had no
idea where anything was and this space
is basically allowing us to
be way more efficient and be way more
organized and work with a lot more
people on our shoots finally more than
anything else since we've been working
on bigger and bigger projects over the
last few years we realized if we want to
be treated as professionals we kind of
have to
look and kind of organize ourselves like
professionals so just look and organize
though nothing
yeah it's just it's kind of a con it's a
facade how do we use this for shoots
what does it look like when we're gonna
like prepare for a shoot and like what
is all this space for well come and
check it out
one of the first rooms we go to when
we're having a shoot is our new and
improved prop room way more space for
all this junk we've been collecting over
the years such as jake's fake hand
the pulse rifle from our gravity gun and
all of
freaking links arrows and swords and
stuff but basically
we keep almost
essentially all our stuff in here now
all our props we got everything from our
crazy tether helmets here we have our
mustache and wig bin everything's
actually on the beat bad guy helmet it's
a really really really great spot for
just kind of picking and choosing
everything and we've been collecting so
much junk over the years where it's kind
of like we don't need to get any other
stuff because if you want to sort you
got a sword if you want a gun you got a
gun and if you want a boot
get a boot
and we have so many cool things in here
everything everything from
pack vests to
freaking
there's so much crap in here elk antlers
in front of our pizza signs
yep that's a prop room so once we get
our actors all dressed up we come out
here a little bit and we say actors
which gun do you want to shoot today you
want to shoot this laser pistol with a
crazy sight or do you want to shoot a
normal old-fashioned like assault rifle
or a freaking hunting rifle or a
a dubstep gun well typically we'll pick
them out for them instead of that but
i think you get the idea you want a
minecraft sword and get a minecraft
sword actually what usually happens is
like when people come to the studio you
need one spot where they can go whoa
cool yeah and so when we walk here into
this like hallway and we got this they
go whoa cool can i take a picture and we
go yeah sure and then we're cool guys
yeah
once we picked out all our stuff
sometimes we're like hey you know what
we actually need to mess with it or
tweak it or kind of build something or
maybe there's something wrong we got to
fix it it's broken so that means we come
in here to this dark chamber called the
workshop where we now have all our cool
tools set up ready to work on we have
everything you ever want you got a
workbench
got a soldering iron
got a ruler in case you got to get
specific
and you got a drill here in case you
want to make a hole in something
so it's pretty great that's pretty much
everything you could possibly need it's
a workbench no everyone's got this in
the garage okay no big deal this is our
merchandise we don't have a lot we're
coming out with more later that's all i
got to say
corridor-digital.com is about to become
a real website so uh we have this hidden
hallway
uh with tables
that takes us to our giant loading door
right there
boom back in the camera room yep so here
in our camera room obviously we this is
where we keep
all the stuff all the hardware all the
junk we shoot with
everything our cameras including our
nice our nice baby red here
and we have our awesome like light
panels over here we've got some light
panels we have our cool
high-tech
space age carbon fiber tripod hidden
away in here which is
a sackler tripod it is super high-tech
and super lightweight it holds even the
heaviest of jib arms we have
phantoms just kind of chilling out over
here waiting to be repaired
from our superman shoot we have
cool batteries being charged we have
cool radios being charged we have
everything in here that you'd ever need
to run a film crew pretty much so we
just walk in here pick what we need
throw it on our backs
well here we're pretty proud of this one
this is my new baby
baby all the gopros we use for lance
party are finally organized
into this one complete high-tech package
which is just foam and gopros and
memory card screen gopro batteries
random accessories if you guys are
working with more than one person one of
the best ways to get organized is
actually to have a server the server is
really just a computer you can build a
cheap one put a bunch of hard drives in
it run some ethernet cable to your desk
and then you can all connect to
basically the same storage work out the
same spot you don't want to reconnect
files you don't have to hop around
computers you can also work off of one
computer and that's what we do so for
our server we just have a basic computer
nothing too crazy uh we have 12
terabytes worth of hard drives in a raid
configuration i think it's raid 0 and
then another 12 terabytes of hard drives
backing it all up so we have copies of
everything
then it's all just going out with
regular gigabit ethernet to our
computers and we all get to work off it
runs red footage just fine no hassles no
troubles no worries yes and we have an
amazing new network also up here that
was installed by spencer the hound
skoglund and he's color coded everything
he has a meticulous eye for detail when
it comes to networking computers
together and
it just happens to be really colorful
and beautiful and i like to come in here
every morning
but yeah actually having this camera
room
is immensely useful when we have to like
get ready for a shoot especially the
bigger shoes like
when we rolled out for like the
assassin's creed piece or
even like the the poacher piece which is
coming up which you guys haven't seen
yet organizing all this stuff and
bringing it all back is so much easier
so much quicker and saves us a lot of
time time that we'd rather spend editing
and writing rather than putting stuff
away so let's check out one more cool
little room that's secretly hidden away
in the back
[Applause]
minecraft
stuff bang
also
back before he was famous he had not
signed our pickaxe and the pickaxe broke
so used it in a movie but his signature
is still there
a little dusty
hey
come in here
this is our
neat little audio recording room that
has been installed we have uh audio foam
on all the walls to kind of help prevent
reverb and
we kind of just like to hang out here
because it's nice and quiet and smells
nice but also because it's a really
really good place for us to do uh music
and sound design so when we're on the
last stages of a video i typically come
into here and sit in complete solitude
listening to the sounds of our videos
and trying to throw new cool ones in
there and uh it's really really really
helpful because honestly when you're
recording that kind of stuff when you're
in a huge room like that there's tons of
reverb and all the sounds you record
sound really weird so just come in here
slide the door shut
whoa
and now it's quiet
it's pretty quiet everybody needs a room
where they can kind of be by themselves
have to be quiet so they can focus on
writing
or mainly just writing actually getting
creative
um or meetings actually when you have
people come over and you wanna have a
meeting and
sitting next to your computer is not the
best spot for it
this room is a great spot for it
sometimes when you need to give someone
a good talking too they come in here and
sometimes clint comes over and we play
the drums together
only a projector too so we can put uh
videos on the wall
that's pretty cool
nico's got big plans to start a color
grading session in here but i haven't
seen it yet
the reason we actually got such a large
space something that's almost like a
little bigger than what we need is
because when we're basically moving into
these larger projects like
you know like tether and stuff like that
the idea is that we want to turn this
place into a full-fledged i guess
production studio where we can have a
team of 12 maybe even up to 20 people
all working at the same time we can run
this as a full production studio and
basically do everything in house so to
speak so it's kind of future proofing i
guess the way we work a little bit it's
gonna be really exciting when that
happens and i'm looking forward to that
anyways guys that's the new studio uh a
lot of cool stuff a lot of great tools
for making videos it's really helping us
do some cool stuff so
it's nice to be here and thanks for
supporting us guys because we wouldn't
be here if you guys weren't watching
them it's time to finally give away a
drone from the superman video just like
we were talking about doing so 33
191 people shared that post so we went
through using a little bit of a script
here to collect all the names and index
them and then i ran a random number
generator the lucky winner after
matching up the number with the name was
james singfield who uh is in currently
in montana so james
congratulations i'll be sending you a
facebook message
if you don't reply to that facebook
message in a couple weeks
i'll have to give the drone to somebody
else so check your facebook messages
congratulations james i hope you enjoyed
the drone i hope you get some sweet
shots of montana i want to say thanks
again to taylor from dronefly.com he's
the guy who's sending out the drones um
he's the guy who helped us make the
video possible so if you guys really
want a drone of your own go check out
his site he's got a lot of cool stuff on
there
also a lot of cool things for mountain
gopros and cameras and all that kind of
stuff as well to everybody else who
shared the video and entered the contest
thank you very much for your support and
getting the word out there it was an
honor
to see how many views the video got so
to everyone out there thanks once again
it was a total blast this video blew up
unlike anything else we've done so it
was a pretty cool experience that's it
that's the drone contest congratulations
james
i hope you don't crash it in your first
day of flying
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]